This is a record of a verification pass over LabeloxAV, run
against the live system.
Three things were done.
More real data was downloaded and ingested, every readable interface was called to see what answers, and the HD map was
taken end to end for the first time.
Every number spoken here came from one of those runs.
Two KITTI raw drives were downloaded from the public archive and imported, adding four hundred and eighty five frames that each carry a synchronised Velodyne scan, a GPS fix and the
drive's own calibration.
A third drive stopped part way through its download and was
left out rather than imported half complete.
The corpus now holds 1,049 point clouds and about 159 million
real laser points, against eighteen million before this pass.
Measured ego poses went from one hundred and fifty four to
639.
Everything else in the corpus is still estimated from single camera depth, and the tooling says so on every page that reads
it.
This is a drive in the session inspector, with the camera, the
laser and the GPS on one clock.
The point cloud here is measured by a sixty four beam scanner, not inferred from pixels, which is what makes the three
dimensional work on this session checkable.
Before this pass no session had both lane annotations and a
position fix.
One hundred and fifty seven frames of forty two thousand carried a fix, and not one of them had a lane, so the map
could not be built at all.
Lane proposal turned out to run locally rather than only on a rented GPU, so it was run across a drive that already had a
fix on every frame.
One hundred and ninety nine lanes on one hundred and fifty four frames, with forty one rejected for sitting off the
drivable surface.
Those lanes were then georeferenced into world space.
One hundred and ninety nine map elements, every one placed
using the drive's own calibration rather than a nominal lens.
That distinction is not cosmetic.
With the wrong lens this projection put a lane six metres ahead at fifteen metres, and one at seventy metres at over a
kilometre.
Fusion merged those into fifty three continuous boundaries, and the topology layer paired twenty nine of them into lanes
with three links between them.
The exports now carry twenty nine lanelet relations and fifty
eight driving lanes.
Both formats previously carried zero of each, which meant
neither was a map anything could route on.
Every readable interface was then called against the live
database.
Three hundred and fifty two of them.
Two hundred and twenty answered, fifty three refused properly, forty four could not be reached because this corpus has no identifier to fill the address, and one returned a server
error.
The four hundred routes that change data were not called, because firing those blindly would train models, launch paid
jobs and delete work.
The failure was the annotator branch listing, which returned a bare server error whenever the versioning service was not
running.
That service is optional here.
Assignments, tasks and merge requests are all in the database
and work without it.
It now refuses with the reason and says what is unaffected, which is what every other optional path in this codebase
already did.
Three thousand five hundred and six tests pass with nothing failing, seven hundred and three in the web suite, the
typecheck is clean and the import contract holds.
Seventy two of the seventy three pages load without a problem.
The one not checked is the sign in screen.
Two things in the map are not yet trustworthy and are worth
saying plainly.
Fusion produced one boundary eight and a half kilometres long on a drive of a few hundred metres, which is a merge running
away.
And the median paired lane came out two and a half metres wide where a German lane is three to three and a half, which says the pairing is still matching things that are not the two
sides of a lane.
The layer runs end to end.
The geometry underneath it needs work, and calling that
finished would be the easiest thing to get wrong here.
So the honest summary.
More real data is in, every readable route has been called and one genuine failure was found and fixed, and the HD map runs from a camera frame through to a routable export for the first
time.
The human verdict count has not moved: 788 of 600,133 labels
carry one.
That remains the thing most worth fixing, and no amount of
code changes it.